die Buckelpiste des Grauens willkommen
auf der schlimmsten Straße Englands eine
Tortur für Fahrer und Autos
gleichermaßen das straßendisaster
befindet sich im Westen Englands nahe
der Grenze zu Wales in einer kleinen
Dorfgemeinde der Name des Dorfes renbery
kam Schlagloch wenn es nach den
Einwohnern geht seit me als 5 Jahren
laufen Beschwerden bei der zuständigen
Stadtverwaltung ein seit mehr als 5
Jahren ist angeblich kein Budget für
Reparaturen da inzwischen gibt es hier
174 Schlaglöcher auf einer Distanz von
200 m selbst der örtliche Automechaniker
ist sauer denn vor lauter Reifenflicken
sieht er kein Land mehr auf dem Facebook
Account der Gemeinde machen sich die
Menschen Luft teils mit typisch
britischem Humor teils mit purer
Anarchie ein Anwohner hat ein Warnschild
aufgestellt diese Straße könnte ihr Auto
zerbrechen und ihre Seele übrigens nach
diversen Medienberichten soll die
Stadtverwaltung inzwischen eingelenkt
haben im April wird repariert heißt es
bis dahin Daumen gedrückt auf der
Buckelpiste des
Grauens
ه